ça me manque
ça fait dix ans que j'ai pas touché
normale après ce qui s'est passé cette
nuit là évident
j'ai comme qui dirait rengainer mon
colts mais sans ce coup du sort vous
allez vous en sortir je l'aurais jamais
connu ça
j'aurais jamais eu mes enfants papa aime
qui après midi je t'aime tu intérêts
monsieur ce ailleurs vous êtes la toute
première famille que nous accueillons
dans la partie résidentielle de the
pearl à l'issue de votre audit de
sécurité
que pensez vous de la tour de pearl et
la structure ultra haute la plus
sophistiqués au monde
c'est une prouesse technologique mais
c'est difficile de prévoir ce qui
arriverait en cas de problème
[Musique]
salut les gars
que ça brûle le 96e est en feu sarah
écoute moi le feu va progresser vous
devez monter ne vous arrêtez pas ne vous
retournez pas ok [ __ ] owen on
attendait ma famille est à l'intérieur
tournez-vous
surtout regarde pas en bas
c'était pas mal hein
moi je me suis jetée d'une grève
voilà l'homme que nous cherchions cette
tour protège quelque chose que je veux
et tu va me rapporter rien n'était
impossible quand on est motivé
non
ensemble on y arrivera j'ai peur
c'est normal d'avoir peur
pour être courageux avant il faut avoir
un petit peu peur
on doit sortir de cette tour tu veux
bien être courageux pour moi oui papa
nick et moi
[Musique]
à